Luke dancing with Dan from Australia
nice to meet you this is my first Super
Bowl oh I want you to give me in one
sentence what is it what is it about
this weekend man you know it's just a
combination of a lot of great football
games you know I've got a present for
you yeah it's a little bumper baby burn
equipment guy not for me I don't have to
do any of that nonsense funny though
well what what balls you have that going
with are you looking to go in with hard
balls or soft balls this weekend what
we're gonna go in with 13.5 psi balls I
think that's a way regulation toughness
regulations up that's exactly what size
balls you need to have to run a nine
point five billion dollar operation but
still call yourself a non-profit pretty
large balls who does ad D NFL are
they're non profit yeah sounds like a
conspiracy